les débuts sont timides d'un côté de la
pièce 10 filleuls en recherche d'emploi
de la Fondation agir contre l'exclusion
Yvelines et de l'autre dit par un
professionnel du château de Versailles
avec des domaines de compétences variés
par des jardins e-commerce maîtrise
d'ouvrage public accueille ou encore
surveillance après une photo souvenir la
septième édition de la job Academy est
officiellement lancée l'objectif que
l'on a à face c'est de faire en sorte
que nos bénéficiaires retrouvent en
quelques mois une nouvelle façon de
retrouver un travail de faire en sorte
que ils aient un projet professionnel
pérenne durant trois mois les binômes de
la promotion Blaise Pascal se
retrouveront tous les 15 jours pour des
rendez-vous individuels avec un diplôme
de sciences de l'éducation Jérémie
espère devenir professeur des écoles en
primaire dans la recherche d'emploi on
se retrouve assez seul finalement quoi
que ce soit pour rechercher des métiers
ou ce genre de choses et avoir quelqu'un
avec qui aurait conversé échangé sur
différents aspects de la recherche ça
peut être très intéressant et
enrichissant en tout cas Rémi et
son troisième fois
la nuit
une recherche d'emploi et lui aussi il
trouve son intérêt pour moi c'est un
enrichissement personnel une activité
humaine aussi puisque on va découvrir
quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas et on va
mettre tous les moyens du château de
Versailles pour essayer de développer
des gens un projet qui peut-être est
déjà très mûri à ce que je vois déjà on
a fait un petit peu connaissance et on
va essayer de faire ensemble que ça que
ça marche en fait les binômes
participeront aussi à 8 ateliers
collectifs comme les clés pour
convaincre les recruteurs ou encore
l'importance des réseaux sociaux et des
réseaux professionnels on continue parce
que d'abord ça marche c'est d'une
efficacité redoutable puisque 70% des
filleuls qui sont rentrés dans ce
dispositif ont trouvé un emploi à
l'issue de leur parcours et puis au-delà
de l'efficacité c'est une rencontre
humaine de très grande qualité et depuis
son lancement en 2016 une centaine de
personnes ont été accompagnées par la
job Academy